[Musica]
che bello a natale inutile fare i figli
tanto gesù vi vede che dietro l'albero
di natale mettete meno pallina nel 2017
come avete visto tutti ho portato un
sacco di giochi di qualità e quindi oggi
ultimiamo con in gioco supremo siamo su
and simulator shamik made per fare il
latte shooting per sparare figisc
spinner horror che non solo la sia
iniziano con mick made e apprezziamo
questi 5 euro spesi su steam
non lasciatevi trarre in inganno perché
un gioco del genere richiede abilità e
strategie videoludiche quindi partiamo
subito la prima cosa che mi viene in
mente che ho due mani però posso muovere
solo quella destra va bene ma ben mi fa
piacere che riesco sempre a ricordarvi
il perché vi siete iscritti al mio
canale per i contenuti di qualità
ragazze allora la partenza deve essere
buona quindi fammi vedere con che
maestria afferri la mammella zio quindi
questo io non sono proprio esperto di di
mucche quindi dovrei strizzare strizza
ok perfetto perfetto si strizza esce
tutto esatto è esattamente così ragazzi
potrebbe sembrare una cosa ed è per 5
euro ci hanno messo anche i colpi di
scena in questo gioco sorella mia mi sta
vagliando tutte le scarpe nuove 800 euro
da gucci scarpe cazzi tuoi poi
allora mi sto cosa ti incazzi affare che
ti ho solo chiamata vacca non ti ho
chiamata ex ora cosa c'é qua siamo in
debito di un pugno sulla spalla mi come
la vedi di non far pagare deve arrivare
al finish che anche tanto mi dicono è
questo potrebbe essere un problema però
va bè noi strizziamo come non abbiamo
mai fatto prima dato la mano sinistra
che cosa è appoggiata esattamente spiega
con gli animali ci vuole pazienza
ragazzi fate faceva il contadino in
un'altra vita in un'altra vita dove non
dovevo spread va da sola a calcetto
automatico e la madonna le vacche del
tieni la gamba tutti nella cava ferma
sembra un po che io le stia facendo
delle cose sconce alla gamba ad una
velocità supersonica tra l'altro ti sta
riempiendo no
ma perché ma non è ma ci sono dei buchi
invisibili in questo secchio quanto deve
essere difficile fare una spremuta di di
bakka ma mi fate capire come facciano a
farmi calciare il secchio qualcuno lo
vuole spiegare
gira secchio gira gira secchio maria in
casa delfino questa adesso aspetta che
vado subito infilato cinque euro ben
spesi comunque shooting in questo dovrei
essere più bravo pistola prima cosa da
fare per quando si maneggia è una
pistola e usare la mano quanto sono
storto non riesco neanche a prenderli
proietti spiegami a ok ora non è
difficile prendi un proiettile amico mio
prendi un proiettile 1 con due dita si
piano inserito qui dietro no porca vacca
spinners ci sono anche fides p su questo
gioco mi fa piacere a saperlo allora
standard document cosa devo firmare un
documento da firmare prima di usare il
finger spinner va bene figurati a fare
la firma se la prende la penna prenderla
prendere la penna
ok è sempre comunque la firma migliore
di quella che ho io require ed a ok
perfetto i problemi nel tener dritta una
penna gesù ma ha fatto firmare però la
penna l'ho buttata giù ragazze loro
giusta diventando frustrante non riesca
a prendere un acca di penna una penna
una pena e non giulia rendi quella
[ __ ] penna in mano a ecco poi firmato
firmare così limidi sedimi che si manca
il gioco posso firmare attraverso la mia
mano
non lo so allora prendi fice spinner e
infila drone rendita e vediamo come
funziona su fides p vediamo non funziona
così un file spinner non funzionano
rotea non fa niente però non so non sono
capace dovrei tenerlo con due dita mezzo
però non impossibile o perfetto fallo
spinare sbattendo contro qualcosa o
perfetto obiettivo raggiunto ragazzi ho
dovuto maltrattare una palma finta per
fare questa cosa però ne è valsa la pena
[ __ ] hilfiger spin e con quale
gravita me lo stai dicendo tra l'altro
va bè ragazzi ultimo livello vediamo che
prelibatezza ci hanno preparato il
creatore di questo gioco horror e già
oro quello che ho già fatto zio però va
bene
vediamo
salve signor a una stretta di mano ma
mentre ma io sono legato cos'è
sono legato a una sedia bene mentre sta
vecchia mi si sta avvicinando ciao
vecchia mi fa un pò schifo con le nonne
però va bene si faccia una doccia posso
palparla sì non può sopportare
ok io proverei l'ultima volta a fare la
cosa che più mi ha dato soddisfazione in
tutto il video secondo me i ragazzi
tutto il gioco è tarato per non riuscire
a finirlo credo e poi magari non è così
ti disintegro la mammella manco fosse
l'ultima che sembra una cosa veramente
brutta quella che sto facendo
considerando anche quello che sta
uscendo però non è come sembra
smettila
ultima da scalciare quanto io ci passa
la giornata qua te lo giuro ragazzi vero
che il video vi sia piaciuto per me
portarvi i contenuti di questo tipo è
sempre un piacere nel senso che quando
io penso al gioco da fare l'impegno per
dare maggior qualità possibile
a questi video quindi io spero vivamente
che vi sia piaciuto che abbiate gradito
questa incredibile giornata di gameplay
a giochi divertenti
spero che video vi sia piaciuto cose se
vi piace quanto è un mi piace anche vari
social che come ogni video trattare la
descrizione che sta sotto la crosta giu
schifani sta giù se siete ancora
iscritti iscrivetevi
ci rivediamo prossimo video beh ragazzi
4 ho notato adesso che parte il fatto
che mi posso spostare marecchia e tv
come quando ti si addormenta al braccio
durante la notte che torni trovi sotto
il cuscino poi ti svegli e tutto e tutto
molle tutto così uguale
[Musica]